steve
[Music]
are you an og i'm gonna switch i am such
an og selena gomez is making it clear we
have to put some respect on steve martin
and martin short's name we're the oakies
on thursday the actress posted a tick
tock video with her only murders in the
building co-stars teaching them some
slang that perfectly describes the
iconic actors okay so what are we just
talking about that might be nice we're
the og's honey yeah steve
are you an og i'm gonna switch i am such
an og and clearly martin is a fast
learner as he gave steve some
pronunciation feedback
no you don't hit the g like that oh
g-e-e oh yeah
oh gee
[Laughter]
this isn't the first time selena has
taught these ogs some 21st century lingo
last month she revealed to et that she
educated her co-stars on the meaning
behind cardi b and meg the stallion's
song [ __ ] which we can't explain here but
the music video might give you a hint
i'm talking
that's some wet and cushy macaroni in a
pot that's some wet and
wait selena did you explain [ __ ] to them
i certainly why can't you say w.a.p
because that's not what they say that's
not what the kids that's like calling
the usa usa
[Laughter]
thank you for this service selena what
did you guys think when you learned the
meaning of wap well well i you know i i
i've known it for years that was like
on top of keeping each other on point
with cardi b lyrics the actors are also
doing the same when it comes to their
new hulu series which follows selena
martin and steve as neighbors who band
together to start their own true crime
podcast after a mysterious murder
happens in their building we're gonna go
down there and look around for clues you
wanna come
do i want to break into a dead guy's
apartment and go through all his
sounds like an afternoon
right now the only thing that matters is
that there's a killer on the loose in
our building
selena also told et that partnering with
stephen martin for the show was a
no-brainer after taking a break from tv
for almost a decade after wrapping her
disney channel series wizards of waverly
place in 2012. how different was the
experience of doing this show to that i
mean you've grown so much since then
what was it like well this was different
i when i was on wizards it was four
cameras live audience five days a week
really fun and this one was just one
camera well we had a couple cameras i
guess yeah but um
but it was a bit yeah movie style so
there was the difference already but i
just enjoyed it more because i felt like
i could concentrate a bit more on the
character and just have fun with it i i
felt like i could just have freedom to
do whatever i felt like she could do did
that feel good to you to play this
character who was so
in her own um is so confident in herself
yeah i do think a little bit of the
character rubbed off on me because i
feel i'm definitely more sarcastic and
dry as i always was and i don't know i
guess it was just freeing yeah
i think it's true though you're playing
more internal than i've ever seen you
more internal and that actually brings
out more
variety it's strange like the deeper you
go inside the more vivid the character
becomes